slightly offensive bowling animations
what's something that's offensive and
makes everyone angry
[Music]
[Applause]
we are here today to kick off another
challenge to make a slightly offensive
bowling ball animation the kind you
would see in a bowling ball Arena
so you know bowling ball alleys have the
weirdest oldest animations
so I've seen my clip circling the
internet again recently just like two
weeks ago and when I see something that
I've made regurgitated it's a sign that
I need to step out there and you know
take another shot at it you guys feel
the same I think it's important that we
make something that is so so slightly
offensive that people have no choice but
to share it the slightly part yeah gives
the part that we've all had a little bit
of trouble with
or some of us some of us you know I've
got
it oh
he's gone too far
[Music]
yeah but only one shot was removed not
the whole thing so the far less guilty
than you it's a
pizza because what offends one will not
offend another I feel I feel Nico you
kind of
Nick
what I'm looking for here is comedy
clever use of ideas and interesting ways
unexpected juxtapositions that Delight
the mind to be offensive requires no art
because you could just be offensive to
be slightly offensive yes that is where
the art enters the equation I know you
have an idea I'm picturing it yeah it's
very offensive well maybe it's not I
don't know it's not it's not over the
line though but it's tasteless that's
for sure
I'm gonna go a little more abstract this
time I don't want to land right on a
massive Humanity
I don't mind human tragedy as long as
there's a Twist you know
we have one day to work on this because
frankly we can put company resources to
something more appropriate and better
you know I think the less time you spend
it the longer it exists in like
society's mind I'll see you guys day
after tomorrow
so things are currently underway I'm
hard at work on my bowling animation I'm
committed at this point but the longer I
work on it the more I have my doubts
maybe I'm missing the Mark again I don't
know if we can do this when I need to
the first time I went too far went over
the line the second time I pulled way
too far back when we played it in front
of everybody the reaction was so muted I
was hoping for something more visceral
it didn't seem to have the impact the
longer I work on it in an isolated way
the more I start to doubt myself I gotta
Branch out I gotta get some opinions I
just gotta find somebody else to bounce
off Sam feels like the perfect person he
wears this when he does motion tracking
tracksuit
the joke I like I like it I like it
again right now I just want to pop in
and see where you're at see what you're
working on and kind of get a temperature
check maybe yeah well I'm not gonna lie
I'm like I'm having like writer's block
huh I was like man I actually I really
don't know what to do so it just cleared
my head I was like what's something
that's offensive and makes everyone
angry and people don't like and I took
that and then I just replaced it with
bowling balls and pins and like I'm
calling it a day like I'm I want to be a
straight shooter I feel like that's what
I tried to do on the first one you know
what happened well yeah what happened
was I think you took the moment that
people found insulting and offensive and
refused to cut away from it making it
more of an this was it was more of a
test of endurance the approach I like to
take here which is like little bursts of
offensiveness but oh that's spicy oh why
hell oh you're gonna get in trouble oh
and then then you level it off with like
or we're cooling off and the cool off is
the goofiness you know so what is some
of the goofiness that is alleviating the
tragedy here late 90s early 2000's
animation style so like look at this
look at this that's so good it's so
aesthetically like on point just imagine
we're going back in time you have a
computer that doesn't work very well you
can't have a lot of rendering happening
in general so we're talking about
Reflections you want to have minimal
Reflections minimal lights minimal
shading low polygons it's like what was
I doing in like at the end of Middle
School like that's my barrier my kind of
visually separating us by crudely
rendering them I think it gives us a
little more leeway to explore these
types of jokes because of how just
Preposterous and silly that they look
they'll never earn us forgiveness that's
for sure but I think it definitely helps
soften the blow I'm hopeful that this
time around I've kind of hit the nail on
the head yeah you're a clever guy I
trust you I think something good will
come out of this one
thank you personally I have to see what
everyone else is working on we all have
experience doing it so I think
everything we're going to be looking at
will be a polished gem
foreign
so before you is the line we'll watch
each animation and if you think that
animation crosses the line AKA it should
be banned and locked away you step over
anyone who doesn't cross the line is now
complicit in everyone in the animation
that they just watched the real goal is
this right here oh this is where you
want the audience to be I'm super
skeptical of Jordan's ability to deliver
something safe enough for YouTube so
we'll see I've changed I've evolved as a
human being and I am 100 confident that
I have found the middle point I really
want to watch these well do you guys
want me to you want me to step up and
take the first shot here all right yeah
Nico all right all right guys I've been
practicing getting pretty good
lay on it
oh that is good
[Music]
[Applause]
oh my God damn that is genius Samson 911
jokes have played out
he proved wrong
what'd you guys think
yeah
I'm right here let's run on that one
perfect I don't think it's safely on
this side of the line wow Bravo that was
incredible yeah all right so let's go
baby all right so here's what's going
down all right I'm doing great I'm I'm
going up boom strike check out what I'm
gonna do the second time
there you go Kyle
[Music]
[Applause]
thank you
oh
my God that was really good
okay Sam you have nailed the aesthetic
yeah the original bowling animations I
love like the dancing pins right when
they all lean forward in the car and
like Get Some Noise together sound
design is the best part so those are
Koopa sounds
I was like I was just like I need to
find like weird gibbery kind of sounds
like they're just Koopa sounds and then
Carmageddon two sound effects oh yeah
take our place
drunk driving and child death
comfortably comfortable comfortably oh
yeah look at that look at that
[Applause]
yeah
all right Dean anything to say
yeah so I'm gonna go up to the line I've
gotten a strike every round this is my
last
turns out
oh and it works
foreign
[Music]
hello
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
this is really good I think I am at a
good distance from the line though I
might try and make my daughter not look
at the screen but my grandma she'd be
okay I'm glad I had to reel it in from
Nazis
all right Jordan all right Lord be with
me
and Claire the year honors in his career
[Applause]
[Music]
three in a row
oh look at that oh my God
turkey wow
oh God we are we are at the peak of our
craft I can tell you you are a master
wow you're too kind
[Music]
I love the mean like thuggish like
pilgrims walking up the
least the one from the band animation
I thought we'd give him one more shot of
the big screen I mean this one's
incredible these are all really good
actually the winner will be decided by
whoever can spot their animation out in
the wild if this is your first time
watching this video and you're just like
what the heck but you you secretly want
to watch more when there's no one else
around you we have other ones on screen
here you can see the other slightly
offensive bowling animations that we've
made that should probably not watch with
other people unless you're really
comfortable with them
thank you